como regalos rusos para las fuerzas
ucranianas en la psiquiada ciudad de
bagmut los disparos de las tropas de
kiev tienen un sello de precisión
enemiga varios tanques utilizados en la
defensa de esa urbe hacen parte del
armamento ruso que ha sido capturado por
el ejército local
es poderoso esta pieza armamento nos ha
sido regalada por los rusos se llama
nona de cvk
tiene alta muy alta precisión y ahora
funciona en su contra nos ayuda a
alejarlos Y es que ante el avance de las
tropas ucranianas las fuerzas rusas
huyen dejando atrás importantes piezas
de uso militar en particular estos
tanques de fabricación rusa fueron
capturados a principio de año y fueron
reacondicionados por los ucranianos
según el diario de Wall Street journal
el número de tanques y vehículos que se
les retira la z característica y se les
reacondiciona para el uso de Ucrania es
considerable hasta principio de octubre
se contabilizan unos 421 tanques 19 dos
vehículos blindados Y al menos 44
lanzadores múltiples de cohetes la
situación en ese enclave de tamiesk es
compleja pero al parecer las nuevas
adquisiciones cumplen con su función
hubo muchos disparos antes bombardeos de
su lado y de nuestro lado Ahora hay
menos bombardeos de su lado y también
estamos disparando menos en las últimas
semanas las tropas ucranianas
desarrollan una contraofensiva bagmut es
un enclave importante para las fuerzas
rusas que progresan lentamente a través
de Daniel apoyados por el grupo
paramilitar Wagner una leve mejora en
esa zona para Moscú desde la toma de la
ciudad desde Lisi chance y se dieron a
mitad